San Francisco continues to become the
human poop capital of the Western
Hemisphere what is their mayor concerned
with ecigs yeah she signed an ordinance
banning vaping sales a first of its kind
in the United States now you don't have
to vape to see how idiotic this is but
let me offer a plug they being got me to
quit smoking which is far more harmful
if they thing had been around thirty
years ago so would a lot of your
relatives
I don't vape anymore but it helped get
me here the mayor says there's much we
don't know about these products but she
could have said the same thing about
wind farms or cell phones but no she
means vaping so vaping is the health
hazard in her city as opposed to
injecting heroin on the streets near a
school I guess when you can't address
your city's big problems you look to
vaping as a distraction from failure and
what's pink done does sf is a monumental
failure it's become a dystopian open
sewer in which the super-rich liberals
virtue signal from above while the ohm
las' relieved themselves below it's
clear that you can accept any kind of
misery if you're well enough away from
it and so the rise in banning things
will continue unless of course the
homeless do it or an ephod does it or
undocumented aliens do it then breaking
laws is simply the right thing to do
because anything else would be hateful
so welcome to SF please don't puff but
by all means poop